welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host definition and you're locked
into the channel where we break down all
the latest movies TV shows games and
comics as chosen by you the viewer this
episode we're going to be going over
DC's latest comic book movie Joker and
why all of the clocks in the film are
set to 11 minutes past 11:00 this motif
pops about several times throughout the
film and in this video we're going to be
breaking down why this could be as well
as what director Todd Phillips and star
Joaquin Phoenix have said about the
theory there will be heavy spoilers here
so if you haven't had a chance to watch
the movie yet and don't want anything
room then I highly recommend that you
turn off now the last thing we wanted to
is wipe the smile off that face so this
is your last chance to back out without
the way I just want to give a huge thank
you for clicking this video now let's
get into our breakdown of why all of the
clocks and Joker are set to 11 minutes
past 11:00 okay so I've been talking to
youtuber wars to you about this theory
for the past couple of days and we've
both kind of been giving up our theories
on it I'm just gonna cover what I think
this signifies but make sure you head
over to his channel after this video for
more theories like this and I'll link it
in the description below so you can see
more of his stuff anyway throughout
joker almost every time that o'clock is
seen it points to the time 11 minutes
past 11:00 this seems pretty deliberate
and now Todd Phillips denies that it has
any meaning behind it it pops up far too
often just to be a coincidence
unless someone on the set is just really
really lazy the first instance that this
happens in is during Arthur's meeting
with his psychiatrist sat in her office
he talks about his mental state as well
as the Journal of jokes that he's been
keeping though the hilarious jokes in
there all caught our attention the first
time around when re watching the movie
on the back wall of the office you can
see a clock set to 11 minutes past 11:00
though this doesn't seem like anything
special during the conversation the talk
back and forth moves to Joker's time in
Arkham Asylum and we do a quick cut him
trapped in a Cell banging his head
against the wall in the top right in a
similar position to the psychiatrist's
office we can clearly see another clock
set to the exact same time now I'll get
into what I think this means
later but to me this is set like this at
the same time on purpose in a similar
position for a very specific reason
later in the film Joker is fired from
his job as a clown for hire for taking a
gun to a children's ward upon leaving
his job the character punches out and
dramatically smashes the clock off the
wall that is used to keep time cards
again the time on this is exactly 11:11
and once more it carries forward this
motif of being a specific time that a
big moment for the character happens
another appearance of a clock later in
the film comes when Joker is in the
dressing room of the Murray Franklin
Show we get a look at a clock that
displays the time around 10:40 and no
this is not the time that we've been
obsessing over in the video this for
it's a safe assumption to make that by
the time Joker gets on the show and
eventually shoots Murray that it would
be roughly about 11 minutes past 11:00
now whilst this is purely guesswork I
think it fits in with the prior evidence
in the movie and its immense for me at
the very least that this has been put
there for a very specific reason now if
we go above and beyond in our research
then the numbers 11:11 have a very
special meaning to them that dates back
over centuries and has been present in
our culture for a very very long time
this is because in the King James Bible
Jeremiah chapter and verse 11:11 the
following passage can be found therefore
thus saith the Lord behold I will bring
evil upon them which they shall not be
able to escape and though they shall cry
unto me I will not hearken unto them
this pretty much sounds like it is
referring to jokah directly was very
much getting revenge on a city and
people that he abuses wronging him which
we see throughout the film those who've
seen the film us by Jordan Peele may
also remember that 11:11 pops up
throughout that movie and is referring
to the same thing that I believe that
jokah movie is hinting at anyway another
theory that seems to be gaining weight
because of the time on the clocks
throughout the movie is that the events
of the film on the whole may be taking
place predominantly in Joker's head
first off we know that the character is
prone to delusions throughout the film
imagining that he's on the Murray
Franklin Show as an audience member
secondly in believing that he and his
neighbor Sophie are having a romantic
relationship both turn out to be untrue
and it's possible that this brief
glimpse at the asylum that we see early
on in the movie and then at the end are
actually the real circumstances that
Arthur is in and he is simply making up
the story The Joker famously states in
the graphic novel The Killing Joke by
Alan Moore that if he has a past he
would prefer to be multiple choice and
this story that is shown purely from
Arthur's perspective could be made up by
the character in order for him to weave
a narrative that he was the son of a
rich billionaire that cast him to the
side and he ultimately ended up bringing
down the family by causing an uprising
where he was seen as a hero it's
definitely possible and it does seem
very strange that the clocks in the
movie are all at the exact same time
when Arthur has a defining moment in his
life search is leaving his job or
getting revenge on someone that
nationally mocked him though it seems
like there is a lot of evidence to
support this however Todd Phillips is
flat-out denying it has any correlation
at all and in an interview with cinema
blend the filmmaker said the following
when discussing the matter it's a
coincidence no I mean I don't know I
think it's a coincidence that's two
times is there another time no no that's
just interesting backing this up Joaquin
Phoenix also said the following when
asked about the theory and if the
numbers held any significance Paul is
dead Paul is dead the Beatles what I'm
saying is I do know that there are some
things that we put in whatever the f you
call them yeah I mean I think some of
them you might read into that's the Paul
is dead joke that I'm making but no
eleven eleven it didn't mean anything to
me personally but those who don't know
this Paul is dead thing is a reference
to the conspiracy theory that was
floating around the 60s that had some
fans believing that Paul McCartney of
the Beatles had died and being replaced
by an actor that had plastic surgery in
order to look like him so that the band
could continue to make money for the
record label I don't want to get too
much into the detail of it as it's a
little off topic but it's definitely
something that's worth looking into if
you have any more questions on it
there's a lot of evidence to support the
theory but then why didn't they do it
when John
and I look never mind back to the
subject at hand it looks like they are
both being pretty coy about this and
denying that there is any further
meaning to it so hey maybe it could just
be that a broken clock is Right twice a
day I really don't know but personally I
think it seems far too much of a
coincidence to simply be put there
unintentionally could Phillips himself
be lying about it I don't know but it
adds another layer to what is already a
film full of Miss cyrex false truths and
events that are guided purely by
perspective which massively makes this
movie worth returning to for one more
visit just to see if there's anything
else that it could be hiding this is a
film that is about someone who doesn't
have a full grip on reality and it's
great watching people question every
aspect of the movie and really picking
it apart it shows just how complex of a
film that this truly is and similar to
the Joker himself how much more there is
going on beneath the surface that needs
to be examined it's why the character
has been one of the best films ever
created since his inception over 80
years ago and hopefully this video has
helped you to gain a new appreciation
for the movie so that next time you go
back and watch it you start coming up
with your own theories on exactly what
is going on and why certain things that
are part of the set are made in certain
ways now obviously I'd love to hear your
thoughts on this theory and if you agree
that the clocks ever had meaning to them
or if you just think that it's all one
big coincidence as Phillips and Phoenix
say did the movie happen in his head is
Paul dead comment below and let me know
and if you enjoyed this video then
please like it and make sure you check
out my breakdown of the hidden countdown
in the background of Joker that signals
the birth of both the character and
Batman we went through the entire movie
and pointed out every time the numbers
counting down to their arrival appeared
so it's definitely worth checking out if
you want to see some more fan theories
on the film thank you everyone who voted
yesterday as well I will definitely get
around to covering the other things in
the poll I just wanted you guys to
choose the topic for today if you want
to come chat to me after the video then
make sure you follow me on twitter at
definition whitey or head over to my
discord server which would be linked in
the description below those are the best
ways to keep up to date with all the
latest videos on the channel so
hopefully you see over there very soon
we're also giving away a free copy of
the Marvel phase 3 part 1 boxer
which contained Civil War dr. strange
homecoming Ragnarok amor and all you
have to do to be in with the chance of
winning it's like the video make sure
that you subscribe to the channel and
leave your thoughts on this theory in
the comment section below the winners
gonna be chosen on the 15th of November
and the set will be shipped out from
then to ever get surprised it's the best
of luck to everyone who takes part this
is a channel for people who are super
into superheroes so if that's the kind
of thing you like hit subscribe thanks
again for taking the time to watch this
I've been definition you've been the
best and I'll see you next time take
care peace
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you